will they be able to drive away the
darkness before all of our burring and
humanity is swallowed up
and at what cost one way or another the
saga comes to a close the banner saga 3
begins just like the last installment
did by throwing you into the middle of
the series is ongoing story chapter 16
this time it's a seamless continuation
of the series that began four years ago
meaning this third and final chapter is
not a good entry point into the series
even its recap cinematic relies on a lot
of assumed knowledge but stoic Studios
banner saga formula featuring lavish
hand-drawn art a satisfying turn-based
combat system a beautiful awesome
wintery soundtrack a compelling Nordic
inspired story and branching choices
with consequences is still as successful
as it was in the first game and this
final chapter provides reassurance that
the trilogy has maintained its strengths
from beginning to end where the first
two entries in the series revolved
around war and refuge respectively
banner saga 3 focuses on desperation as
an all-consuming darkness slowly
destroys the world story again follows
the perspectives of two different groups
one is a large mixed race clan who have
fortified themselves in the city of
Arbor Aang which serves as the final
bastion of all who still remain the
other is a smaller group of mercenaries
traveling towards the center of the
darkness with a magical escort hoping to
reverse its effects there's no longer
one particular race or group that serves
as the primary enemy rather the main
adversary is the infighting between
everyone as the situation worsens
different clans war over power in Arbor
Aang unable to see the bigger picture
and interpersonal conflicts plague the
mercenary group who also have to deal
with new enemy creatures warped by the
darkness there's a time limit until all
is lost the series is visible day
counter which previously counted up will
now eventually take down to zero and the
high narrative stakes will also see
major characters take riskier actions
with greater chances of having them
being lost permanently depending on the
choices you make although the inherent
satisfaction of the game's combat system
can exist without context nearly every
other aspect of the Banner Saga 3 relies
on having some prior knowledge for
meaningful enjoyment for example combat
units who enjoyed significant character
arcs in banner saga and banner saga
2 may only have a small handful of light
in three which can give the wrong
impression of flimsy characterization
starting a new game from within three
will let you make a major binary
decision that arose
the end of Banner Saga one but the
multitude of other choices and potential
consequences from the first 20 or so
hours of the series are made for you and
the game doesn't spend time reading the
complex relationship between characters
unique races and the world itself but if
you have played through the first two
games and ideally imported a save file
through them both then you'll have a
much better idea of how catastrophic
things are going into Banner Saga 3 in
this situation the final game does a
wonderful job of taking the discrete set
of experiences you've had with your
roster of aspiring characters as well as
your long-term resources that you've
acquired and using them as emotional
leverage creating meaningful personal
impacts as the story climaxes and
concludes I've had a bad feeling that
these things will never again return to
the way they once were
even if we succeed desperation also
informs additions to the turn and grid
based combat system the signature
mechanics remain strength is a valley
that informs both your health and attack
power meaning the less healthy have the
weak year attack an armor value protects
against strength damage and units can
choose to focus an attack on either
strength or armor world power returns as
a limited resource that feels unique
character abilities as well as allowing
you to overexert in basic actions to
either move further or hit harder but a
significant number of scenarios are now
wave based helping to characterize the
relentless tides of enemies trying to
lay siege to our brain and stop the
mercenaries at all costs failing to stop
a wave in a set amount of time results
in enemy lineups stacking together
resulting in an overwhelming number of
adversaries and all but certain failure
successfully defeating a wave gives you
the choice of continuing to fight or
fleeing the battle as well as an
opportunity to substitute the characters
in your active force completing an
entire battle will reward you with a
high-end item to equip the higher
narrative stakes and the stronger
enemy's means that you need to fight
diligently the circumstances mean there
aren't many opportunities to give your
characters time to recover from
debilitating injuries after battle if
they fall and even when you do get a
chance to make them rest it's at the
cost of precious time before the
Doomsday Clock runs out
failing or fleeing a battle after a wave
or two can also have negative
consequences in the plot the
substitution system is engaging because
it not only asks you to draw from the
sizable roster of characters you may or
may not have collected and kept alive of
the past two games but it
man's that you keep them all upgraded
equipped and battle ready rather than
letting you rely on a small stable
roster the Banner Saga 3 calls for all
hands on deck and motivates to make the
most of what you've gathered in the past
to stay prepared for the worst the worst
will come in the form of new warped
enemies mutated and more powerful
versions of the series existing units
whose behaviors add new emphasis on
spatial considerations all warped enemy
variants explode upon dying creating
hazardous squares and require more
careful movement around the battlefield
other environmental elements like
spreading fires and exploding ice shards
feel like bigger considerations to sum
around and are more inviting to take
advantage of strategically given the
more numerous opposition one significant
Haulover annoyance remains from the
previous games however the fixed
isometric perspective of combat means
units can often obscure the contents of
the grid tiles behind them and while
you're given the opportunity to utilize
a handful of new and exciting units
yourself depending on your choices
there's a lot that's become absent since
the Banner Saga - even though they might
fit the narrative combat training and
challenge missions have been lost as
have a lot of the series as cloud
management interactions while you'll
still need to keep an eye on each
group's overall morale supplies and
population there are very few
opportunities to bolster these resources
the Banner Saga is no longer a game that
revolves around traveling and recruiting
and growing but one that's a constant
task of trying to stave off attrition as
best you can
during the last end as things come down
to the wire with the two separate groups
becoming more and more interconnected
the consequences of one group's actions
directly affect the potential of the
other this exemplifies the best part of
Banner Saga 3 the feeling that every
action you've made in regards to your
clan for three games the friends you've
kept and lost the decisions you've made
and the battles you've picked will
likely influence how well this finale is
gonna fare for you the Banner Saga 3
won't have the same kind of meaningful
impact if you haven't experienced the
rest of the series but if you've taken
the time to journey with these
characters from the very beginning this
finale is a worthwhile a cathartic end
to your long journey all I care about
now is that the friends
no the family I fought to deliver to our
brown left to see the Sun move again